I live in Northeastern Montana where there are very few holistic doctors.
Most of them don't even check my adrenal health or know what the saliva test is.
Okay, I think this person is talking about the salivary cortisol test.
So there's a there's a adrenal stress test, adrenal health test that's tested salivary cortisol over a period of a 24-hour period.
I think that's what they're talking about.
About six years ago, there was an antropathic doctor who treated me for adrenal fatigue.
It was very helpful, but she's no longer there.
I think I need a test for cortisol levels again.
My question is will doctor cutters be willing to work with me on the folder email for the distance?
Okay, the answer is that so that is yes.
You could just call our office and schedule an initial consultation with me or you could just go to our website.
Hit the schedule now and you'll go to a schedule page and you could self-schedule yourself.